ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ถ้า
วันนี้ครูเรียมข้างหลังสีสีเขียว
ใช้ค่ะข้างหลังสีเขียวก็กูเองสีขาว
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เตรียมเปลียดเปลี่ยนเป็นสีเขียวค่ะ
ครูเรียมวันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้
วันนักเรียนบอกว่าครูเรียมครูเอ๋พูดว่า
เดี๋ยว
วัดวันอาทิตย์ชัยค่ะวันอาทิตย์ใหญ่
ใส่ยอมวันนี้วันอาทิตย์แต่ถ้าวันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
5 มั้ย 5 ชัยขาววันที่ห้า
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคม
ใช่ค่ะเดือนธันวาคมพ.ศ.วอันธิที่ 5
วันนี้วันคุณพ่อ
หน้าให้เขาวันคุณพ่อของคนไทยคนไทยพูดวัน
พ่อรักพ่อคืออะไรครับทุเรียนมพ่อ
เป็นผู้ชาย
แล้วก็แต่งงาน
แต่งงานกับแม่
แล้วก็มีลูก
ใจค่ะแล้วก็มีลูก
ไอ้ตัวเล็กๆ
ลูกอา
ก็เลยเป็นวันนี้วันพ่อวันนี้วันพ่อค่ะลูก
ก็จะไหว้คุณพ่อ
ใช่ไหมหาวันที่ 5
วันที่ 5
วันที่ 5 วันเดือนใช้เขียนธันวาคมราคา
แล้วปีคศอะไรคะตัวเองมีข้อ
2021 แล้ว 2,000  21  - ปีพศ.อะไรคะ
2,000  564
กิน
ข้าว
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะถ้าหน้าเดือนธันวาคม
ค่ะ
คศ
2 คัน 21 แล้วก็ปีพตต
2564 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อโคเรียมอะไรคะอีก
eaa
26 วันขอเหอะอีก 26  16 วัน 5
ซอยคะปีคศ
2000  21 จะไปแล้วหมอ
หมอ
2021 จะไปแล้วใช่ครู
ก็จะจะเปลี่ยนใช่ไหมคะถ้าปีหน้าก็ 2,000
22 นเออขอ 2,000
มองไม่เห็นโอเค
ปีหน้าเนาะปีหน้าก็สองด้าน 22 มี
26 วันนะคะ
ป๋อแต่ว่าปีนี้ปีนี้ยัง 2,000 บาท 21 นะ
คะๆปีนี้ 2021
เครี่ยงคลิปนี้
เรามีอะไรมาให้นักเรียนดู
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
โคเรียมผู้หญิงครูเอ๋ผู้หญิง
ใช้หา 5
เมื่อวานเมื่อวานทำไมคะเมื่อวานเดิมไป
ซื้อซื้ออะไรอา
นา
her ซื้อต่างหูตุ้มหู
ภาษาไทยพูด 2 คำเนาะต่างหูตุ้มหู
ใช่ค่ะ
นักเรียนต่างหูเนี่ยต้องมี 2  2  2 ข้าง
ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะต้องมีสองข้างนี่
มีข้างอะไรนะกูเองที่ทางไหนอ่ะค่านี่ซ้าย
เอกที่ถูกมั้ยทางสายกูครั้งสายแล้วก็ต้อง
ขวาทั้งขวาทั้งสายก็
โอเคค่ะต่างหูจะมีข้างซ้าย 1 ข้างทั้ง
ซ้าย 1  1 ข้างใส่ได้ไหมครับใส่ได้ค่ะกู
เลียมส์โอ้โห
ต้องดึงออกก่อนใช่ป่ะดึงออกค่ะเด้งออกเอง
ออกเราก็ใส่มีที่เสียบใช่มั้ยก็ใส่ไว้
เจ็บเว้ย
เฮ้ยค่ะ
f ได้ไหมได้เสียได้
นะคะใต้โอเค
อ้าใส่ต่างหู
ข้างซ้ายนะคะร้ายรับข้างขวาใส่นะคะใส่ค่ะ
ใส่ต่างหูข้างขวาได้ค่ะต้องเดิม
เสียบค่ะ
เสียบเข้าไป
เข้าไปอยู่ไหนอยู่ไหนหาหารูโหมันจะมีมีรู
ใช่ไหมมีรู
แล้วก็จะมีอากาศเสียบใส่เข้าไปดูโห
เจอไหมเธอ yeahh อ๋อๆใส่ได้แล้วอะแล้วก็
ล็อคล็อค
โอเคนะอ่าตัวเอกมีรูหูไหมคะอ้าเอ่อครูเอ๋
มีเล็กๆแต่แกรู้เอ๋เอ๋รูหูไม่โอเคไม่ได้
ใส่ต่างหูครูเอ๋มีไว้
คู๋คิดว่าไม่มีค่ะ
ไม่มีต่างหูเรียม
ก็ครูเอ๋ไม่ไม่ใส่อ่ะกูเอ๋ใส่แล้วเจ็บ
เจ็บป่ะเออกูเอ๋พี่ไม่ชอบใส่ต่างหู
คู่เรียมชอบต่างหูแล้วมีต่างหูมากไหมคะ
มากๆค่ะ
นักเรียนอยากดูไหม
ครูเลียมนักเรียนพูดอยากดูหมออยากดูหน้า
โอเคค่ะนะเรียนยาดูตั้งฮุกครูเรียมมีมาก
เท่าไหร่
ครูเอ๋คิดว่าเตรียมมีต่างหูกี่คู่
คิดหลังคิดคิดมีมากใช่ไหม 10 คู่
1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10
นักเรียนคิดว่าครูเหลี่ยมมีต่างหูกี่คู่
คะเด็ก
อีดอกหน้ากูอีกขาวมาก
โอเคเรามันนับก็มันนับกันนะคะค่ะ
นี่ค่ะ 1 คู่ละ 1 คู่ 1 คู่จะมีสองข้างนะ
คะ 2555 มีข้างซ้ายข้างขวาค่ะนับเป็น 1
คู่
1 คู่ค่ะ
ทำไมเหมือนกัน
ไม่เหมือนไม่เหมือนก็ล้มเหมือนกันอ๋อแต่
ไม่เหมือนหรอไม่เหมือนค่ะน้อครูเอ๋ดูแล้ว
คิดเหมือนกัน
ไม่เหมือนตรงไหนอ่ะ
อันนี้อ่ะ
ค่ะเป็นยังไงคะอันนี้เรียบออกขอ
[เพลง]
มีใบไม้
ใบไม้ต่างหูคู่ที่ 3 เหมือน
ใบไม้ใบไม้ใช่ค่ะเป็นสีอะไรคะตัวเองนี้คน
ไทยพูดสีเงิน
งูจิงานแบบนี้ค่ะแบบเนี้ยสีเงินอาหาร 4
เรื่อง
การโหสีเงิน
สวย
ครูที่สามผ่านไปผ่านไปแล้วเออคู่ต่อไปคู่
ที่ 4
คู่ทิศ 4 สี
แดง
[เพลง]
สีแดงๆใช่ไหมมีสีแดงใช่ค่ะอ่ะโอ้โหสีแดง
ถ้าเป็นอะไรเป็นหินพลาสติกหรืออะไรเป็น
หิน
หญิงคู๋ไม่เห็นไหมอยากคุยหากัน
เป็ดทอดนี้
เห็ดกี่คู่แล้ววันนี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ก็แล้ว
แบบ
แข็งๆใช่ตัวเองไม่เห็นสีสี
แต่ว่าถ่ายไปไหน
ครูเอกก็หาหาเห็นหาหิน
ออกก้อนหิน
ใช่หินสี
ชื่ออะไรพี่สีอะไรคะสีน้ำตาล
สีน้ำตาล
อ่อนน้ำตานะคะ
อ๋อ
ต่างโหอ่าของหูเรียมเป็นหินสีแดง
สีแดง
สวยสวยๆ
ผ่านไปแล้วกี่คู่แล้ว
4 คู่
her ครูเอกว่าคู่นักเรียนคิดกี่คู่ไม่
รู้
ต่อไป
คู่ที่ 5 คู่ที่ 5 ค่าแรง
อะไรเป็นกลมกลมๆออกข้างในมีใบไม้ๆค่ะสี 4
ลง
คู่นี้สวยซื้อที่ไหนคะ
สำเพ็ง
ฮ่าๆๆขอใกล้ๆไชน่าทาวน์ประเทศไทยนะฮะใช่
แล้วค่ะ
ต่างหูที่สำเพ็งเยอะมากๆค่ะกี่คู่แล้ว
เนี่ย
55555 เอาไปกลับไปคู่ชิ 6
คู่ที่ 6 ค่ะคือที่ๆๆ
[เพลง]
เป็น
มุก
ไม่ค่ะกลมๆคนไทยพูดมุก
[เพลง]
สวยว่าง่ายบางที่กู
คู่นี้สวย
ครูเอ๋ชอบ
เอาไปดู
แต่ครูเอ๋ไม่ใส่ไม่ใส่ครูเอชอบดูไม่ชอบ
ใส่
อาหมอเดี๋ยวลืมถอด
อ่ะถอดคู่กลมออกนะคะคอร์ด
chord ออกค่ะแย่แล้วก็ใช่
สวยๆชอบๆครูเรียมใส่คู่นี้
อ๋ออ๋อใส่คู่นี้
ครูเอ๋ชอบดู
เสียบโหยค่ะเสียบเข้าไปเนี่ยดูหูซ้าย
แล้วก็ล๊อคค่ะล็อคล็อคค่าเก็บไว้
เจ็บไม่เจ็บนะ
สวย
สวยๆแล้วก็
ใส่
เสียบ
รูโหขวาค่ะอ่ะเอา
งูแต่เขาก็ล็อค
งู
สวย
[เพลง]
คู่นี้คู่ที่เท่าไหร่หรอค่ะ 6  6 ไม่ใช่
ไหมคะนักเรียนกูที่ 6 เออครูที่ 6 ละถอด
ถอดนะคะ
คอร์ดถังโขค่ะ
เดี๋ยวครูเรียมใจหยิบคู่ที่ 7 นะคะใช่ค่ะ
คู่ที่เจ็บ
เสียง
ผู้ที่เจ็บชื่น
[เพลง]
เป็นเส้นแล้วก็มีกลมกลมๆ
น่ารักวงนานเป็นเส้นนี้สองเส้น
สองเส้นแล้วก็มีกลมๆค่ะครูเรียมชอบกลุ่ม
กลุ่มเนาะ
ใช้ค่ะแล้วก็ชอบเส้นเส้นแล้วก็กรง
เอออันนี้คู่ที่ 7
20 คู่ต่อไปค่ะคู่ที่ 8
คูทิม 18  of กูที่ 8 ก็เป็น Books  are
ใช่ค่ะเป็นมุกแต่ว่า
เป็นแบบหนีบอ๋อไม่ใช่แบบเสียบ
เสียบเป็นแบบหนีบค่ะ
หนีบ
ไม่ต้องหูไม่ต้องเจาะใช่ไหมไม่ต้องมีรูป
โป้
นักเรียนครูให้เราหูเนี่ยไม่มีรูเขาก็จะ
ต้องมีไร
เจ็บเจาะเจาะโหมึง
อันนี้หมี่ปไม่เจาะก็ได้ค่ะครูที่ 8 ใช่
มั้ย
เว็บหูซ้ายค่ะอุ้ยวิโรจน์
โหลด
เลยนะ
เฟสพลอยหลุดเศร้าหูขวาค่ะ
สวย
หืออร่อยค่ะ
ผู้ที่
แพทย์แล้ว
ฟังฟังครูเอ๋ลืมลืมเท่าไหร่แล้วอีก 1  2
3  4  5  6  7  8 คู่ที่ 8 แล้วค่ะ
เตรียมหาๆๆ
เดี๋ยวไปซื้ออะไรมาแปะ
เอ้อ
ผู้ที่ 9 ค่ะ
สีอะไรอ่ะ
สีเขียวสีเขียวเขียวอ่อนๆไหมไม่ใช่
สีเหลืองนะคะอ้าวหรอสีเหลืองอ๋อ
สีออกเหลืองเหลืองนิดเหลืองเหลืองนิดๆ
เรียกว่าเหลือง
อ่อน
เหลืองอ่อนวิธีการก้าว
ข้ามฟันที่ 10 ตัวที่ 10
คู่ที่
ครูเอ๋ๆ
ฮ่าๆๆ
โอ้วสวยดีใส่ที่สั้นๆนี้สั้นๆอะไรไหมคะ
เป็นดอกไม้
ไม้นะ
เหมือนของคู๋นะคะยกมาอีกแล้ว
ดอกไม้
อันนี้
ผอม
เตรียมคิดว่ามันเหมือนกับหยดน้ำอ๋อมีหิน
ตรงกลางใช่ไหมขินใช่เหมือนน้ำอ่าหนูว่าจด
น้ำหยดน้ำนี่หาปากกาหามใช่มั้ยนักเรียน
น้ำแล้วก็
หยดน้ำใช่ค่ะเป็นหยดน้ำ
หยดน้ำ
ครูทิพย์สิบเย้
ถ้าตัวเองทำเปลี่ยนใช่ไหมหมดหรือยัง
ยังไม่หมดล่ะคะ
หมดมีอีกและเครื่องมีต่างหูเยอะมากๆอ๋อ
โต๊ะเป็นมุก
5 ก็เป็นคู่ที่ 14  11  51
กูเรียมบุริมยกถุงเลยนี่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าพ่อร 5 ห่อแล้วก็อะไรที่
มันเดี๋ยวนักเรียนฟังแตกต่างหูต่างหูๆ
อย่างโหเป็นเครื่องประดับผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะ
ชอบต่างหูแบบผู้หญิงชอบอะไรอีกข้างคู่
เรียมครูเอ๋ชอบอะไรคะปูเอกชอบชอบสร้อย
ผมขอจริงๆซอยยังไม่ได้ชอบมากเว็บชอบตัว
นี้ค่ะ
เรียกว่าอะไรคะเรียกว่าจี้หงอ
พี่ครูเอกก็จะมีที่มากๆอ๋ออ๋อครูเอ๋มีตี้
รูปอะไรบ้างคะหน้ากูเองนี่แหละกูอีกมา
ก่อน
จริงๆมีเยอะๆนะคะแบบตัว a ให้ไป
จะหายอีกจะหล่นตัวเองมีจี้สี
น้ำเงิน
นี่สีน้ำเงินใช่ไหมสีน้ำเงินล้อ 5 อันนี้
ชื่อไผ่ลิน
นี้
ใครลินนะคะเป็นจี้พลอยนะพลอยน้องพลอย
ไพลินแต่คู่เอกชอบเล็กๆ
เงิน
ไม่สีสีน้ำมันอุ่นสีน้ำมันกูเองไม่มีแบบ
นี้ไหมคะ
กิน
สีน้ำงานนี้นี่
จี้สีน้ำเงินนะคะที่ไผ่ลิน
จี้สีเขียว
คอสที่สีเขียวเรียกว่าอะไรคะหยกค่ะหยกหยก
หยก
อันนี้จะจีน
[เพลง]
แล้วก็จี้สีแดงเห็นสีแดงไหมอ่ะ
นี่สีแดงสีแดงนิดนึงค่ะสีแดงสีแดง
อ่อน G สีแดงสีสีแดงชื่อ
โกเมน
โกแมนโอเมนค่ะเดี๋ยวมีอะไรอีก
ตี้สีเขียว
นี่สีเขียวอันนี้มรกต
สีเขียวมรกตกดมันแหวนง้อ
ลุคเพชรสีเขียวมรกตสกปรกไม่ได้ล้างผู้เอง
มีที่สีเขียวมรกตและก้อนอิฐที่สีเขียวหยก
ใช่มีสีเขียว 2
แล้วก็มีอีกมีที่
ที่สีชมพูงอย่
ชมพู
สีชมพู
เขา
เรียกว่าอะไรนะคะเรียกว่าทับพิมพ์
ใช่หาครับกินกับซิมนะคะแล้วก็มีอีกไหม
จริงๆนะ
โอเคเองไม่ยกเยอะๆ
เอกชอบชอบหินใช่ไหมคะชอบ
หินอ้อมีอันหนึ่ง
อันนี้อันนี้จากเดนมาร์ก
โห
เป๋อะไร
เตรียมคิดว่าสีส้มเป็นสีสีส้มใช่ไหมครับ
เจ๊
สีเหลืองสีน้ำตาลสีส้ม
รวมกัน
งูเออมี 3 สี
ใช่อันนี้จากต้นไม้ใช้มันเป็นต้นไม้
งู
ต้นไม้แล้วก็มียางออกมา
ผู้เรียนว่าต้นไม้ได้เลยค่ะต้นไม้มีต้น
ไม้
แล้วก็มีอาจจะมีมิตรปากแล้วมียางออกมาอ๋อ
มียางอย่า
ใช่งูอันเนี้ยกากต้นไม้ยางต้นไม้งูพี่
อำพัน
ง้อ
อำพันสี 3 ที่ 3 สีสีอะไรไม่รู้
หนูสวยชอบ
ตัวผู้เก๋น่ะกูเอกชอบชอบอันนี้นะ
ชอบทำคัน
นิดๆ
เป็นจี้เป็นที่เหรอคะคุณเอ๋
จิอูเอไม่มีต่างหูอ๋อไม่มีตังหูแล้วก็มี
อันนี้ก็เป็นที่
โหเป็นที่อะไรคะนี่ทองอันนี้สร้อยสร้อย
ทองแล้วก็จี้ทอง
จี้เป็นท้องลิง
เห็น
นิดนึงอ้าอย่างที่นี่วิ่งนิ่ง
คิดๆๆๆก็มีครูเอกชอบจีไม่มีต่างหูก็จะมี
จีมหาถ้าอยากก็มี
สิทธิ์กำไร
คือกูเล่นกูเอไม่ได้ซื้อนะค่ะตัวเองไม่
ได้ซื้อกูเองไม่ชอบทองเนื้อทองอันเนี้ย
ทองครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบแบบ
คุณป้าให้หมออีกคนให้
ให้ครูเอ๋มาไปสุษมไม่ได้ซื้อชายไม่ซื้อ
ไม่เหนื่อยใส่ใส่อันนี้อ่ะแต่ไม่ใส่ทอง
ไม่ไก่
เก็บนะเก็บรักอะดู
อันนี้ก็เป็น
กำไรค่ะ
หมอกำไรข้อมือใช่ไหมคะน้อยใส่ที่อยู่
มี
กำไรกางเกงน้อยตรงนี้จะเรียกว่าข้อมือถ้า
ก็สวยดีเนาะสวยสวยเนอะใช่ค่ะสวยน่าจะไม่
ชอบ
ไม่ชอบใส่
A มีกำไลข้อมือ
มีที่ใส่ตรงนี้
พี่ใส่ข้อมือ
ตรงนี้เรียกว่ากำไรกำไลข้อมือตัวเองมี
กำไลข้อมือสองค่ะ
เจอันนี้อัน
นี้เป็นทองแล้วก็ทับทิม
หมอใส่ข้อมือ
ใส่ยังไงคะเราเอาเกี่ยวค่ะมี
คะอันนี้แหละค่ะ
มีตรงนี้ค่ะมีต้องอ่าตรงนี้เรียกตะขอ
หมูขอนะคะเอ้าทำไมกดแชร์ตะขอค่ะแบบนี้ใช่
ไหมคะใช่
งานเป็นตะขอแล้วก็มีห่วงขอแล้วก็มีห่วง
อันนี้ห่วงนะคะหัวแล้วก็เอาหัวเนี่ยใส่ใน
งู with ไหนได้ไหมเอกสาย
ใส่ใน 5 ใส่ได้แล้ว
เย้รักใส่ข้อมือแปลว่าครูเรียม
อะไรคะกำไรอันนี้เมื่อกี้กูอียิปต์แล้ว
เห้ยพลอย
ก็
หายไปไหนพลอยหาย
รู๋หาไม่เจอไม่เจอเอกคนๆว่าเคยเห็นนะก็
ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรขายแล้วโอเค TOA คะ
เตรียมเคยเห็นบางคนมีกำไรข้อเท้า
ใช่ๆ
รู้ a ไม่มีอ๋อลูกเอ๋ไม่มีกำไรข้อเท้าไม่
มีไหมนี่มีกำไรข้อมือแล้วมีแหวน
งู Earth จริงๆไม่ชอบใส่แหวนแต่ชอบซื้อ
แหวน
ครูเอ๋มีแหวน
มากๆใช่ไหมคะมากแต่ว่าวันนี้ครูเอ๋มีให้
ดู 3 วงของอเมอันนี้ 1 วงสองวง 3 วง 4 วง
แหวนวงที่ 1 สีอะไรคะสีน้ำงานเมื่อก็สี
น้ำเงินอันนี้ฟรีไม่
เอามีคนให้ดูเอ๋
[เพลง]
ถ้าไม่มีคุณพ่อ
ค่ะสีดำเนิ
คุณพ่อ
คุณแม่เราก็มีนักเรียนผู้หญิงหายอะนี้
เป็นคนญี่ปุ่น
หมอ
คนญี่ปุ่น
เราก็นิครูเอ๋นะคะอ่ะ
ครูเอ๋
คุณอนิดนักเรียนคุณแม่นักเรียนให้
แหวน
ให้แหวนครู a
Host ขอบคุณค่ะคุณแม่
นักเรียนชื่ออังกฤษโกะคุณแม่ให้อยู่ร้าน
น้ำเป็นเส้นเส้นให้ๆดูงงค่ะ
อืมตึงเเผนจากญี่ปุ่น
จากญี่ปุ่น
จริงๆพลอยอันนี้ไม่ใช่ญี่ปุ่นแต่ว่าแหวน
มาจากญี่ปุ่นหมอ
หูสวยค่ะ
สวยๆสีน้ำเงินใช่ไหมคะสีน้ำเงินสีน้ำเงิน
โง่ต่อไปก็มีแหวนอีกนะคะคุณชอบสีน้ำเงิน
สีเขียว
โอ๊ยอันนี้ซื้อซื้อเองนี้ 500 บาท
ไม่แพง 1 วงหนึ่งวง 1  500 บาทใช่เพราะ
ว่า shop และกะ sale  on  sale
sale  sale แล้วก็ปิดไม่ขายแล้วก็เลย 500
บาทล่ะค่ะ 5 ตอนนี้คนคนไทยพูด sale แปล
ว่ารถหลักลดลดลดราคาลดราคา
ใช่ไหมคะเอกจำได้ไหม
น่าจะร้อน
เรียงเห็นลด 10% มาก
50% ไม่ๆอันนี้จริงๆหนึ่งวงหนึ่งวง
ประมาท
3,000  4,000 บาทผู้หนึ่งวง
งูคู๋รถ 90% ประมาณอ่ะ
คืนร้านปิดไม่ขายไม่เอาแล้วเดรสราคามากๆ
โหก็ทั้งหมดเป็น
เครื่องประดับนะคะเครื่องประดับหาเครื่อง
ประดับ
ก็จะมีอะไรบ้างคะมีตังค์ Help  me ต่างหู
ราคา
มีสร้อยใช่ไหมคะสร้อยมีสร้อย
แล้วก็จี้เด็กที่นะคะนี้มีกำไล
เราก็
แหวนแหวน
ๆ
เลยค่ะด้านมากๆผู้หญิงผู้หญิงคุยกันนาน
ว่าตื่นแล้วจะมีทั้งหมดเวลาแล้ว
คลิปหน้าค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ
ม.ค